Voiceover: So we're pretty
familiar with the things
Benjamin Franklin did later in his life,
but let's just start with the beginning.
Where was he born, what
was his childhood like?
Voiceover: He was born in Boston in 1706,
he was the tenth son
of a Puritan immigrant,
and as the tenth son of a Puritan,
if you've studied the
Puritans or your Bible,
you know your supposed to be your father's
tithe to the Lord.
His father was gonna send him to Harvard,
in order to study for the ministry.
This was way back when...
Voiceover: And so when
people tithed, I've always
imagined tithe is you give
ten percent of your income,
you always give ten percent away of your,
I guess they consider
that part of your wealth.
Voiceover: Right, well it
was indeed, tithing means
giving away ten percent of your wealth,
but if you were the
tenth son of a Puritan,
one of the kids was
supposed to be a minister,
and in this case it was old Ben Franklin,
young Ben Franklin, was
supposed to be the minister,
but he was not exactly cut for the cloth.
You know one day they were salting away
the provisions for the winter,
and he said to his father,
"Why don't I say grace
"over 'em now, we get it done with for the
"entire year, we can
bless the entire food!"
Yeah, instead of every day. (laughing)
Voiceover: And so I think
his father realized that
it would be a waste of money to send him
to Harvard to study for the ministry,
so instead he apprentices him,
makes him become an apprentice
to his brother James, who was a printer.
He was apprenticed at age
12 to this older brother
who was a printer.
Voiceover: I see, at age
12, and that's essentially,
you go do what your brother's doing,
this is your education,
I mean, back then...
Voiceover: That was the
way you got educated,
but in return, you were
bonded, you were bound
to work from age 12 and, usually for,
I don't know, seven, eight years at least,
for an older brother.
And if you've ever had an older brother,
this was not something
Benjamin Franklin liked after a few years.
He rankled over authority.
That was one of the ways
he was very American.
And so he has to decide to teach himself,
because he's not going to Harvard,
he's not in school.
His father decided instead to make him
an apprentice to the older brother,
and so he teaches himself how to be a good
writer by pulling down the
books from his brother's
print shop and publishing
house's bookshelf.
He started off with like,
Bunyan's Pilgrim's Progress,
and you know, the essays by Plutarch,
and Swift, and Defoe, all these things
you and I were reading at age 12...
Voiceover: Absolutely! (chuckling)
Voiceover: And then he
taught himself how to write.
He would take the Spectator
magazine, which was
a great magazine in
London at the time written
by Addison and Steele, and it would arrive
by the post to his brother's print shop,
and Franklin would grab
it and he would write down
the arguments that Addison and Steele did
in their essays, and
then he would chop 'em up
with scissors, he would
cut them up, and put it
in a different order, and then try to
rewrite the essays in a better order than
Addison and Steele had done.
This is like a, he's by
then 14 or 15 years old!
(chuckling) This is really
cool, it's like using
Khan Academy to teach
yourself, but your using
the Spectator from England instead.
Voiceover: And so he becomes, he actually
does start writing then, i
guess he, but his brother
didn't really wanna...
Voiceover: Right, his
brother wouldn't publish him,
as I said, he was an older
brother, even though he
became a tolerable writer,
he can't get his stuff
printed in the New England
Courant, which is his
brother's newspaper, so
he has a little trick.
He disguises his
handwriting, and he makes up
a pseudonym, and he
writes under a fake name.
These wonderful essays, he's 16...
Voiceover: What's the name that he uses?
Voiceover: Silence Dogood. (chuckling)
These are the Silence Dogood essays,
and you're talking about a
kid who is aged 15 or so,
making up this character.
Now Silence Dogood was a woman.
Now here as I say, this
is a boy who's a pretty
troublesome kid, Ben Franklin, he hangs
around the docks in
Boston and gets himself
in trouble all the time, and he's always
cutting work at his brothers print shop,
but he invents a
character who's a widowed,
older woman, who is dating a minister,
and living out in the countryside.
Voiceover: So pretty much the exact
opposite of himself.
Voiceover: Right, (laughing) and it shows
something so important in education,
which is how do you let
the imagination triumph?
And here's a kid, 15
years old, who invents
this character, Silence
Dogood, and just does
a pure thing of the imagination.
She was, indeed, the
opposite of Ben Franklin,
but there are lots of
traits that Ben Franklin
gave her, and every week she would
write about them, that
sort of made you realize
okay, it's a bit like
Ben Franklin, because
she had this, she wrote
once, "I am a mortal
"enemy to arbitrary government
and unlimited power.
"I'm very jealous for my
rights and my liberties."
In other words, she's a very spunky woman
who has an aversion to tyranny.
And it was a great description not only of
Ben Franklin, but of the country that
Ben Franklin was helping to invent.
Voiceover: And this is,
just to give people a
historical context,
this is well before the
American Revolution and independence from
Great Britain, I mean we're talking about
the early 1700s, we're
talking about the period
around 1720...
Voiceover: Yeah, we're
talking about 50, 60 years
before we really are
gonna have a revolution
and break away from England, but already,
he believes in liberty,
he believes in an aversion
to tyranny, and fighting these things.
And you see it in the
way that Silence Dogood,
every week, she would write
an essay until he finally
got (chucking) found out by his brother.
He makes fun of the connection between
church and state in Massachusetts,
because the governor, [Dunstrin], Dudley,
all these people, they
are Puritan ministers
who are also the
governor, and the heads of
the legislature in
Massachusetts, and he says
of Governor Dudley, he said, "anybody who
"goes from the clergy into government will
"take your money in two different ways,
"they'll do it under the guise of taxes,
"and then they'll do it
under the guise of God,
"asking you for a donation." (chuckling)
And so, this little kid
pretending to be an elderly
woman is making fun of
the connection between
church and state in Massachusetts.
It's the beginning of a
free press in America.
Voiceover: And that's a big deal,
the church was fairly powerful.
Voiceover: In Boston in
particular, as you know,
it was settled by the
Puritans, and it is a
theocratic colony, in other words,
Harvard University, the
colony of Massachusetts,
and the Puritan heirarchy
were all the same.
I mean it was all the same people,
Cotton Mather and Increase Mather,
and Governor Dudley,
they were the ministers,
they were the people who ran the state,
they were the people who ran Harvard.
Voiceover: So Silence
Dogood, I guess we said that
she's the opposite, she
was maybe demographically
the opposite of him,
but philosophically...
Voiceover: Right, he's
using somebody who's
totally a different
type, an elderly woman,
to express his own philosophical ideas
so he doesn't get caught by his brother.